il ya très longtemps j'étais le seul mec
dans un groupe femme et je me laisserais
tout tapé à berlin une autre rumeur elle
travailler et le respect va s'arrêter
quelques instants là dessus parce que
c'est quand même des moments avons pas
dans la vie de des huit jeunes chaînes
de télévision vous avez quel âge à
l'époque j'avais 21 ans vous savez
comment elle m'appelait et ça aurait de
gros tuyaux mais ce type et et pas trop
dans le journal qu'ils avaient déjà la
mèche
toutes les semaines je me savais que
tout le monde et j'invite tout le monde
à télé câble sat demain à l'appeler gros
tuyaux d'ailleurs sans plus de relance
lansol hashtag gros tuyaux